so what is the
role of the holy spirit this holy spirit
has many roles
and for us sinners his central role is
conviction of sin
as early as genesis 6 3 let's read verse
it came to pass when men began to
multiply on the face of the earth
and daughters were born unto them that
the sons of god saw the daughters of men
that they were fair
and they took them wise of all which
they chose and the lord said
my spirit shall not always strive with
man
one of the functions of the spirit of
god is to convict a person of sin
and eloise tells us the first step in
reconciliation to god
is the conviction of sin so the spirit
begins at the very first step in the
transformation of a life
by convicting the person of sin it is
also by the spirit that a person
learns the truth john 16 13 how be it
when he the spirit of truth is come he
will
guide you into all truth jesus prayed
for the disciples or he told them
he will ask the father john 14 16 and i
will pray the father and he shall give
you another comforter
that he may abide with you forever even
the spirit of truth so one of his very
names is the spirit of truth without him
no one can properly
understand the bible it is by him that
the words of scripture were written
second timothy 3 16 all scripture is
given by
inspiration of god or god breathe and
the breath is a symbol used to refer to
the spirit of god
uh second peter chapter 1 verse 21 holy
men of god spake as they were moved
by the holy ghost or the holy spirit and
so one of his functions
convict of sin one of his functions
teaches the truth
another function of the spirit
remarkably
is to restrain people from doing evil
for instance when someone's probation
has been cut off
the person there's no more chance for
that person the spirit no longer
convicts of sin
but the spirit restrains that person
from exercising
all the evil he or she may desire to
exercise
the four angels on the four corners of
the world revelation 7 1
there are under the direction of the
spirit of god so the spirit restrains
sinners from fully expressing all the
sin that they might desire to express
the spirit convicts us of sin and the
spirit teaches
us the word and the spirit is the power
within us
he brings the very life of christ he is
a representative of christ
and so when jesus said in john 14 16 and
i will pray the father
and he shall give you another comforter
the word
another means another one of the same
kind
there are two words in the greek for
another one is the heteros
the other is a loss in heteros we see
heterosexual
someone of a different sex in allos we
have the same thing
allopathy i guess would be one word on
which ellos might be built
when jesus said another comforter he
said another of the same kind
someone just like me he also when he
said another comforter he himself was
suggesting
i am the first comforter there's another
one just like me coming
to take my place when i depart and so
the holy spirit represents christ
in romans chapter 8 verse 9 if any man
hath not the spirit of christ
he is none of his the presence of the
spirit as a controlling force in the
light
is evidence that that person is a child
of god and so without the spirit you
cannot be identified
as a saved child of god so the spirit
has many many functions but those are
some he was also involved somehow we
don't know the details
in creation we read in psalm 104 29 i
believe it is
thou send this forth thy spirit they are
created verse 29 and verse 30 of psalm
those are some of the functions of the
spirit of god